hello you're playing the waiting game
the video game recommendations show this
week we're running around in
tight-fitting clothing not me thankfully
month or Savannah yes metal gear solid
ground zeroes is slowly sneaking up on
us so we figured it was time to take a
look at some stuff to keep you busy
until the game launches ground zeroes is
the next installment in the tactical
espionage series created by Hideo Kojima
designed to act as a prequel to Metal
Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain ground
zeroes is interesting in the Kadima is
attempting to create a more open world
experience for players giving them
different methods of getting about and
sneaking the item crafting system from
Peace Walker is also returning so short
of hiding in a cardboard box for several
weeks however are you going to keep
yourself entertained step 1 order a
martini okay so James Bond might seem
like a far cry from snakes continuing
adventures in Metal Gear Solid but stick
with me on this one the series of books
and films created by Ian Fleming each
one following the exploits of British
secret agent James Bond has actually
been named as one of the inspirations
for Metal Gear by Kojima himself so it's
a pretty interesting way to get yourself
ready for ground zeroes bond who has
been played by numerous actors over the
years there's a lot of things he's a
womanizer a trained killer a problem
drinker and an industrial one-liner
Factory I've know her for eggs while
some of the action may seem a little
dated tactical espionage basically forms
the centerpiece of the whole Bond
universe making it a good fit for ground
zeroes just watch out for Roger Moore
he's a bit rubbish speaking of Kojima's
inspirations for Metal Gear Solid
there's one more item on our list this
week that's been referenced by the big
man himself red dead redemption
now before you get up in arms yes i know
we've recommended this game before on
the show but that was the multiplayer
see this time we're talking about the
single player in red dead redemption you
play as former outlaw John Marston a man
out to bring down his old gang members
in order to save his wife and son though
there's a slight dip in the middle of
the game the story is one of the best
rockstar has ever produced forming a
close bond between player and
protagonist in a way Metal Gear Solid
also does very well it also helps that
the gameplay is a blast America lying
cheating to Jenna and passport now as I
mentioned earlier the crafting system
you may remember from metal gear solid
peace walker is returning for ground
zeroes bringing with it a much more open
game world is running around an
open-world crafting things is your bag
you should really play far cry 3 Ubisoft
sanity obsessed shooter is one of the
most fun open-world games of the last
few years which is no small feat given
far cry 2 was a bit of a jumbled mess
the game in which you play as a
sprightly American kid trying to rescue
his friends from their ruthless captors
has a vibrant open-world stuffed with
animals to slaughter items to collect
and gear to craft all of it feeding
directly into how powerful your
character is well you can go in all guns
blazing the moment of perfect stealth
are the most rewarding making you feel
like a skilled guerrilla fighter much in
the same way Metal Gear can only instead
of saying what was that noise enemies
are more likely to complain about how
much it burns when they piss it's still
good though it burns like a mother when
I piece should have used the rubber all
right so you've had something to read an
a couple of games to get you ready for
ground zero so how about a film The Rock
is a film directed by michael bay but
please don't let that put you off
starring nicolas cage and Sean Connery
it's a tale of tactical espionage that
sees a Navy SEAL team attempt to
infiltrate San Francisco's Alcatraz
Island and stop the mercenaries who have
taken it over before they launch
chemical weapons over the city and kill
a whole bunch of people Nick Cage might
not be quite as smooth as snake but it's
still a hugely entertaining action film
and one that I've
more times than I care to mention it's
also incredibly quotable so I wouldn't
recommend actually watching it with me
ever and finally this week we've got one
more film for you it's not exactly a
prime example of tactical stealth action
but the similarities to Metal Gear Solid
should be apparent about now I'm going
in this is snake plissken played by Kurt
Russell he's been milling around
Manhattan which has been turned into a
giant maximum security prison in order
to rescue the president an important man
who was silly enough to crash land their
escape from new york is a very silly
action film from 1981 but you shouldn't
need me to tell you it's had more than a
little influence on the Metal Gear
series with some truly over-the-top
shooty action you should really look at
this film as more of a guide of what not
to do when playing a snake in ground
zeroes but it's still a great way to get
yourself excited for the next metal gear
before it actually launches and with
that I'll leave you to it they'll be
more from the waiting game next week but
if you want to have a closer look at any
of the items we talked up in this
episode click the link on screen now for
an ever handy amazon list feel free to
make your own recommendations in a
comment or by tweeting with the hashtag
GS waiting game bye for now